hello everyone and welcome to the second
annual video game accessibility awards
my name is alana ps and i am joined by
the one and only steven spawn
steve you look beautiful
thank you sir we tried to match this
blue even though we're in different
states we're very shiny it's aggressive
listen we are aggressively beautiful i
feel like a disco ball
well you know what you've got that kind
of 70s flavor to you right now i think
it's working for you thank you
steve quick question what exactly is
accessibility in video games
absolutely so accessibility is anything
pertaining to the general access of the
video game just as the word might sound
think of it as you're trying to watch a
baseball game you're standing outside of
a fence and maybe you're a little bit
shorter than your friend who can see
over the fence maybe you need an apple
box or a crate to stand on in order to
see the same beautiful game as your
friend that option allows you to put the
crate in or take it out that's the idea
but i think you already knew all of that
i don't know steve i thought that it was
all about games being easy
oh right sorry easy mode or gtfo that's
right
that's it in a nutshell
all right and cut
so my turn to ask you a question because
the teleprompter tells me to what
exactly are the accessibility awards i
did write that in the script he's very
well behaved so beautiful well done yeah
thank you i wrote a whole sentence i'm
very proud of myself um okay so welcome
to the second annual video game
accessibility awards this is an award
show that is all about basically
uh celebrating games or development
studios that are making strides in
accessibility so making games that are
more accessible and uh more accessible
to uh disabled gamers we do also have an
asl feed which is super super super cool
thank you to chris uh the stream for
that if you want to go to it there
should be a command in my chat is
twitch.tv
deafgamerstv
so check him out that is so awesome that
he's helping us out there um yeah the
goal is really like i'm not hiding the
fact that i have an agenda uh is to try
to get views from how beautiful steve is
it's working oh look at that 75 billion
again get that get that eye candy you
know what i'm saying listen
so i gotta have some purpose to be here
uh no really the purpose is is to try to
get more studios to make more accessible
video games the idea is if we dangle
awards in front of them then they might
need bubbles i exist for those and i
will make them really we just we just
want to celebrate accessibility and talk
about it in a really positive way
because steve i mean i know that you
have spent a lot of time fighting and
you do have to like yell at developers
sometimes to try to make things
accessible so today's all about
positivity
about having a good time
that's today was about pizza and about
pizza do you know how good this smells
i bet it's is it torturing you right now
you're not allowed to eat that's a real
pizza why am i not eating it
so i i just like the before the show the
director's like don't eat the pizza and
lana and she's like damn it i'm almost
definitely going to eat the pizza a very
big thank you to pizza hut for
sponsoring the show and uh our partners
are real good touring and able gamers
for making this whole thing possible and
look this cool
but especially pizza hut it smells so
good
um but of course this is also an award
show we we have a lot of special guests
and a lot of fun stuff planned but steve
just you know to get to the awards part
why don't you explain everyone at home
how exactly voting worked this year
right the awards the reason we're
actually here other than pizza right so
so as you know there's a lot of video
games in the world and we had to narrow
it down to just a few choices so what we
did was we reached out to our partners
over at ablegamers they have an amazing
player panels project that has more than
500 gamers with disabilities who all
have a variety of disabilities and
challenges in their lives and they
individually were able to play these
games and find out exactly which ones
deserve to win this year's accessibility
award they were paid in a lot of ways
including game codes and some people
like chris who we were able to pay to
help do the asl translation again def
gamers tv
yeah so we have a whole bunch of games
that came out in 2021 i just wanted to
address that because i see it in the
chat uh people asking why it's 20 21 so
it's because the games came out in 2021
we got not in 2021 we are not it's not
still 2020 somehow i know better update
my calendar i hate to break it to you
why one yeah that's the way that it is
this is a labyrinth set up
yes i'm sorry this is how we reveal the
pandemic happen to you hope that
everyone is safe um but we did pay one
of other guest i'm just not sure exactly
where he is um
zack anna
has anyone seen zack um
he's supposed to be
delivering pizzas to nominees
but i'm hearing that he's lost do we
have any means of checking in on him
hi i'm zach anner and i'm going to be
delivering pizzas to everyone at the
2021 video game accessibility awards
this saturday march 12th at 2 p.m
pst
pizza standard time
is it just pizza time or pizza standard
is it still pizza standard time or have
we moved into
have we moved out of of
of pizza standard time or are we are are
we in pizza time or
wait is it pizza savings time or pizza
standard time
it's kind of nice how the pizza box
keeps your lap nice and warm especially
in outer space wow it seems like i
stumbled into a conflict here one of you
ordered a medium pizza for this huge
group if they're fighting now all these
guys with one pizza that's gonna be
trouble oh
gosh
so much fighting someone's got the
hangries
it is customary to uh tip
[Music]
i know
he he knows he's supposed to be at the
studio not in outer space right that
looks like a green screen
oh
i don't okay well he'll figure it out
right
um yeah surely yes i have faith that he
will uh okay until then why don't we
just get right into it steve does that
sound good
it does alana okay thanks steve
our first presenter is actually one of
my personal favorite streamers she goes
by sweet anita and she's a twitch
streamer and ambassador from england
hi i'm sweet anita and i'm presenting
the award for training grounds
this is the award for games that give
people a chance to practice how to play
before jumping into a campaign or a
multiplayer match
it's so that people can hone their
skills and improve in their own time
outside of a regular tutorial
training grounds are really important
for all gamers with disabilities because
they allow for experimentation
players can figure out different ways of
conquering the barriers of the game
through assistive technology and take
time to configure all of the available
options
here are the nominees
and the nominees are
halo infinite 343 industries xbox game
studios
[Music]
monster hunter rise capcom
back for blood turtle rock studios
warner brothers interactive
entertainment
[Music]
hi i'm david ellis senior designer on
the academy for halo infinite
i want to thank alana and steve and
everyone who has helped bring the
accessibility awards into existence i'm
grateful to accept this award on behalf
of the entire team of 343
i especially want to thank tom french
bree dyerly and sarah stern for their
partnership in helping to bring the
academy to life
our guiding mantra in the academy has
been to give players a safe space to
learn how to halo games have the power
to give us hope
perhaps more important today than ever
before
and to bring people together from all
parts of the world
when we play games we get to be the hero
of our own story
so once again i want to thank the
accessibility awards for raising
awareness to everyone in this industry
who works hard day in and day out to
help everyone be the hero of their own
story
thank you
[Music]
steve i made the decision not to watch
any acceptance speeches that we received
until now and i'm now thinking that it's
going to hit me pretty hard emotionally
can you support me through this please
at least i have pizza
i don't plan on supporting you at all
and i'm in fact going to mock you
whenever you have feelings i get that
vibe i get that five yeah it makes sense
um no halo infinite is also in the
training grounds is is super important
for a bunch of reasons like that's
something where players can go into a
safe environment like you said and
actually
test things out learn how to play
certain things learn how to reconfigure
controls there are so many ways that
training grounds are really important
and i implore any studios watching to
please consider putting them in your
games
yeah it's unfortunate we don't do
trading grounds in every video game and
it's one of those that i don't
understand why there's at least some
small optional tutorial slash training
ground area training grounds are very
important for gamers with disabilities
to be able to test out features button
sets and allow for presets in the game
before it actually matters so if you're
able to go out and see that a button
combination won't work you'd rather do
that in a training area than when
everybody might yell at you for pushing
the wrong button i think all studios
should allow those kind of options
i can't believe you that was not
scripted
it was not it was not scripted he was so
eloquent
it's almost like that's why you hired me
no no it's again it's the good looks
uh oh okay right oh you can
all right fine all right we'll just go
on now because i'm going to rush live on
television our second presenter is jay
justice who identifies as a queer
disabled black superhero jay is an
editor consultant cosplayer and advocate
joining us from new york city
hi
i'm jay justice accessibility consultant
and developer and i am presenting the
award for peer assistance
this is an award for games that allow
players to bring in a friend to help
them with any pesky challenges that they
can't or don't want to complete alone we
all need a friend to lean on every now
and then and games that let us do this
can be especially important for all
gamers with disabilities who find that
they need a little help with a
particular mechanic or quest
here are the nominees
and the nominees are
it takes two hayes light studios
electronic arts
yeah all right oh god oh god oh god oh
god hurry hurry go go go go go go okay
okay
age of empire four
relic entertainment world's edge xbox
game studios
[Music]
back for blood turtle rock studios
warner brothers interactive
entertainment
if we're gonna do this then let's do it
and the winner is
it takes two
[Music]
hello me and the team want to thank for
the peer assistance award from the
accessibility awards we're very happy
with this award of course this is an
extra special award because
we can include people that normally
can't play a game to play our games and
hopefully we can do more of that in the
future and i see in the industry it's
happening more so i'm really happy for
this thank you very much
[Music]
steve i love him so much i love him so
much
just
i can't it's just a nice nice person in
general uh other than trying to murder
me one time good guy really nice guy
what that's fine don't worry about it
it's a minor thing the lawyers will take
care of it um
that you you know okay
i was uh i was actually pulling very
hard for it takes two we're not allowed
to vote we're not allowed to have any
influence on the awards but it takes two
no votes no votes at all i actually
don't like to let steve have opinions in
general i try to keep those no whenever
i try to talk she's all like you go back
in the corner and i'm like all right
sorry
it was a great game uh you know you and
i were talking about playing it our
friend bruce green asked if he could
play with us you know i ended up playing
all the way through with my friend guy
it's a great game not only because the
fact that they cared about the game and
to make such a stunning example of a
video game but also because they
genuinely care i reached out to them
through a simple means of a tweet asking
them to increase their mouse sensitivity
so that i would be able to play the game
just as a normal ordinary disabled gamer
and within 48 hours they had that
sensitivity up to a level that i was
able to play so shout out to them for
caring they really do i mean it's also
i mean it's cleaned up at a bunch of
award shows obviously it's one of the
game of the year awards it's i'm
so impressed
by the design i spoke to somebody about
it at dice it was like how did you make
this game because it's like a million
different video games in one in a way
that's so impressive and their answer is
basically yeah we just like planned it
out that never happens in game
development it doesn't happen planning
things yeah like we just
you know we have meetings and we plan it
out and we did it
unheard of it doesn't happen it's so
impressive just i just figured out
planning things and having meetings is
how you get things to go on the first
take i just figured it out next year
planning we'll figure it out we did not
have enough meetings
more meetings yes
uh next up we have one of our favorite
people on the planet you might recognize
him from a little film named free guy
that's right the one and only
jacksepticeye oh my god
i tricked you as a trick
he is
it was a trick joke society's an irish
youtuber slash clothing brand owner
slash coffee company owner and another
one of our wonderful award presented
here's jack sean
hi
i'm jacksepticeye inventor of coffee
and i'm here to present the award for ai
assistance this is the category for
games that can detect when players are
struggling with something and provide
them with some handy assistance so that
they can progress
this ai assistance is especially
important for those people with
disabilities who may not be able to play
without these vital assistive options
here are the nominees
and the nominees are
forza horizon 5 playground games xbox
game studio
far cry 6 ubisoft toronto ubisoft
psychonauts 2 double fine xbox game
studios
and the winner is
forza horizon 5.
[Music]
[Music]
so unfortunately playground games were
the only studio we weren't able to get
an acceptance speech from in time
i slid into their dms
i mostly sent out emails for the other
studios
the forza i was like let me just slide
into the dms see how it goes
so you're in their dms and everyone else
is playing the game gotcha yes it didn't
work out potentially my bad um also do
you think he really had that written on
his hands
i
really wonder what kind of great improv
actor also invents coffee and cans
that's amazing too talented too talented
um before we move on did also want to
mention that for anyone who would like
closed captions we do have the option
for you to have closed captions on on
the stream and of course if you would
like to watch the stream with asl you
can go to twitch.tv def gamers tv um
great point but back to forza
i feel like the forza horizon series
especially the newest forza has done
such a fantastic job in terms of
accessibility um it got recognized from
a lot of different websites from a bunch
of uh our friends in the accessibility
space also recognized forza steve do you
have any insight
on what's uh okay
no so no you know the thing about forza
is it's always been a progress in
what can be achieved in accessibility so
first they had the ability to hold down
a gas pedal then it was automatically
break then it was the steer and then it
was to do all these things combined and
it's the progression of accessibility
that has always impressed me with them
now sometimes they backslid a little bit
and some of their games have become less
accessible and then they hear about it
from their audience and they're reminded
why it's important and then they upped
their game again and i think that is an
important feedback loop why it's
important for you the viewer to reach
out through twitter instagram
my little pony carrier pigeon i don't
know how you i don't whatever you have
to do go to myspace uh go to napster.com
are we allowed to say that
limewire is apparently making it muddler
so you should get a hold of those floors
apparently because the way we did it
didn't work so go to limewire tell them
that accessibility is important so what
you're telling me is i should yell at
people on the internet
uh it seems to work for everybody but us
yeah
i actually uh have seen you know
obviously elden ring a lot of people
talking about alden ring right now from
games are
traditionally not accessible
unfortunately they are not good in terms
of accessibility a lot of players having
a lot of issues and
i've noticed a lot of players right now
there's a whole bunch of reddit threads
about a lot of people getting motion
sick playing elden ring that is an
accessibility issue there are a lot of
accessibility issues that might pertain
to you that you would consider yourself
they don't but um yeah motion sickness
is absolutely an accessibility issue i
encourage you to talk about it so
developers can get that feedback and
make more games accessible going forward
it's good for everybody even if you
don't want to use the accessibility
options why not let other people use
them you know
amazing you mean other people can use
options that i don't need and i can
still that's what i'm saying steve yes
have you ever tried putting that opinion
on the internet
in any case uh should we maybe check in
on
zach has anybody seen him
anyone
zack
[Music]
it's really really nice that even though
this is a dungeon they had a ramp wait
is that
so you're fighting not with your
boyfriend but with
your boyfriend as a weapon oh
it's a spouse joust they say that love
hurts but
i don't think they meant that you were
actually gonna be using your spouse as a
sword whoa
watch where you swing that boyfriend
lady maybe it's my inability to become a
weapon that's been holding me back
romantically does anyone want to shove
my leg into anything and see if
it's sharp i
if you want to pick me up and swing me
around
i'm available a single with pizza
ready to be used as a blunt object
modern dating just confuses me
[Music]
uh we didn't um
we didn't hire him to do that he that's
not how legs work
he's not here to talk about his dating
life he's supposed to be delivering
pizzas
to nominees and now he's in a dungeon
trying to
date proposition our audience are we
allowed to do that on twitch
if you wanna at zac energy you can get a
date with his leg i guess
uh i'm going to keep the show moving
before we get pulled off
[Music]
nice
i did it
our next presenter goes by nega oryx
she's a streamer host voice actor and a
really great friend of mine she's
potentially best known for her viral
videos schooling rude trolls while
absolutely slaying as killer in dead by
daylight here's em montgomery
hi i'm a montgomery although you may
know me better by my online handle
nekorics and i'm presenting the award
for ability to bypass
this award is for a game that allows
players to skip cut scenes or those
dreaded quicktime events or
anything really so they can just keep
playing
ability to bypass is designed for gamers
with disabilities who may not have the
ability to
conquer a certain challenge or
mechanic here are the nominees
and the nominees are
life is strange true colors
deck 9 square enix
[Music]
ratchet and clank rift apart insomniac
games sony interactive
entertainment considerably
unpacking
which beam humble bundle
[Music]
and the winner is
life is strange true colors
[Music]
thank you so much ablegamers alana and
steve it's an honor to accept this award
on behalf of the life estranged true
colors team
i am so proud to have worked on a game
that could be nominated for and even win
a video game accessibility award
life is drained true colors is a story
about a woman who doesn't process
emotions the way others do and her
journey to find human connection and
community
so it's especially meaningful to know
that our game has helped to foster
community and connection in the real
world by striving to reach and welcome
disabled gamers
thank you to everyone who worked so hard
to make our accessibility features a
reality especially madeleine tate our
producer in charge of accessibility
abigail flores and all of our creative
partners at square enix and todd
bollinger tom marnell and the rest of
our wonderful programming team
thank you again for this award it means
a lot
[Music]
oh that's so nice steve what happened to
us
well we've been jaded because we
obviously have known jacksepticeye for
too many years have you been raised
wrong how are they so sweet
uh well i think you're supposed to be
nice in this industry but then said we
chose to be sarcastic look at us now
we're only here because like we
organized it we're here because pizza
hut that's why we're here um
you know the truth of it is alana i
could not have picked between these
three i'm glad we didn't have to vote
i'm glad we didn't have to argue they're
all great they all allow you to bypass
and i think by and large whether you are
physically disabled cognitively disabled
you're a deaf gamer or a blind gamer the
ability to get past an obstacle that you
just can't figure a way around or you
don't want to because you want to do it
yourself you don't want to ask someone
else for help the ability to bypass it
that's one of the best accessibility
options there are
absolutely yeah it's super important
it's also something that whenever i've
had a prompt come up and be like would
you like to skip this i always i'm like
thank you i would like to skip this i'm
very bad at platforming
get me out of here you know well i mean
netflix lets us do it to the commercial
so why not wait are we supposed to stand
with sponsors
uh also while we had some time with nico
oryx who obviously presented that award
she is a very big fan of dead by
daylight so we decided to sit down with
some other friends who are also big into
that particular game
yeah we wanted to highlight a game that
has done a great job in terms of
improvement so being maybe they started
out not so great maybe they got some
feedback from the community that's
something we'll go more into in the
video
yeah well let's jump right into it
um okay hello welcome everybody uh who's
joining me today should we go down the
list
i'm alana
i'm edgar hi
where's the list it would be on discord
the discord order of the list
it's on a different pc
to you buddy
hi i'm jason
oh my gosh
hi um
hi uh i'm neko oryx uh today we are
playing dead by daylight which i am
playing on an ultrawide monitor which
apparently is not very compatible and i
apologize for that um but steve and i
wanted to shout out a game that has made
some pretty impressive strides from
where it started out in terms of
accessibility um
so steve wha how did dead by daylight
start out slash all of you uh when it
comes to accessibility like what was the
initial reception as as very big
dead by daylight players
yeah uh dead by daylight was
largely not considered a very accessible
game uh in fact sort of lauded as being
very inaccessible to a large portion of
the disability audience and uh you know
one of the cool things along the way was
that reddit came along to let people
grab a voice to say hey we need to
kind of work on this a little bit more
what's happening to me
uh i got it i got it i got it i got it
what you're being electrocuted did you
do that
steve yeah
i'd just like to say steve i feel like
that's the only story i've ever heard
someone tell where the moral of the
story was reddit did a positive thing
yeah
it happens once every 17 years
from what it looks like last year they
basically
overhauled a whole bunch of stuff and
improved a bunch of uh accessibility
options so we kind of wanted to
highlight you know that you can do that
years after a game comes out and that
you should strive to do that and include
more players um so what are some of the
the new accessibility options we've got
going on i mean there's definitely a
couple things one that i think the
community was asking for
for forever and i know y'all can back me
up on this one but there was one
killer going up against them a doctor
who people just straight up had to drop
out of
matches like they would load in see it
was the doctor and have to dc and then
they would receive disconnection penalty
from it because his
ability include like these sort of
shockwave visuals
that um were triggering for epilepsy
and there was no way
absolutely no way to opt out of seeing
it if you got paired against this killer
that was just it
and
finally finally they listened to player
feedback and they changed it without
changing his kit in a way that like
negatively impacted people who played
him and i think that was such a great
example of
you can listen to the community and you
know make changes that make it better
and more accessible for others without
it doing what so many people fear which
is like hampering the gameplay at large
because it really didn't affect his
gameplay you know the
blend mode was huge too i think like i i
know i i had a friend who couldn't see
like auras like a lot of players which
which you know is kind of important
especially as a killer like being able
to see like kind of where are all the
generators oh yeah yeah when the
colorblind options came out that was
like just so unanimously loved
um because there's even like the perks
and everything that like highlight
generators and things and you're right
like you just you couldn't be but like
certain people couldn't see steve
yes how are you doing
can i help you steve okay so i i do not
have the updated wiggle uh which is the
most recent accessibility update is that
you don't have to match multiple keys
which i currently do and that's the
thing that's really important to me
personally in terms of accessibility um
so that update i think just came out
this week where they basically reduced
uh inputs
which is awesome
uh really transformational for a lot of
people uh you know uh actually the first
time that uh jason ever reached out to
me to play just as friends i was like
well i'm not sure i can do survivor
because you have to hit your keys and w
back and forth back and forth or
whatever you haven't bound to a b
and uh that was that was yeah that was
it was kind of difficult he was like you
want to play and i was like well i don't
think i could do survivor bud and that
was kind of
an impediment to us being able to play
together and i think a lot of people
have that same
frustration sometimes with video games
where someone will reach out to egg you
want to do this and you have to send
kind of back in a frustrating hey i'd
love to but i can't and so yeah yeah
this this it was kind of cool to be able
to you know change that off are you
chasing me
am i being chased by you right now i'm
walking towards you very slowly what if
you didn't what if you went elsewhere
all right i'm gonna go check out this
incredibly adorable ambulance oh my god
this is so creepy down here yeah jeez
edgar's office
oh no
that sounds like very rude of you sir
listen uh i just wanted to say you're on
the hook
[Music]
um no you know the colorblind options
were great and a huge option for dvd and
you know one of the things i really
wanted to bring together three of the
biggest dvd players um you know is
really sort of talk about you know how
did that affect your communities you
know when when they started adding these
things you know was it mostly positive
did you deal with a couple of trolls we
were like and who cares you know what
was really the pulse of the the
community from your viewpoints
i feel like and like
with the exception of
just maybe a couple of people um just
being trolled not against you it was
just
no
no steve spawn sorry
keep going
all the um all the options that they
kept and they would like tear them in
i remember each time one would come out
it was just like i said everyone seemed
to love it
um i think they did the hook struggle
first and then the wiggle meter
and it's i don't know it was kind of
neat honestly seeing um
you know just everyone being just like
so smitten with how uh
with how the options were being added
and then
now it's
like almost it's a completely different
uh
experience for a lot of people
yeah
like steve said he's you know he's able
to play um survivor and stuff because
you don't have to like jam on the
keyboard again though interesting that
he's not you know that's just worth
thinking about he still chose to not be
survivor today didn't he
for being a killer
he just wanted to beat me
explain that steve
i am i will say
something that i mean it was very
emotional if i'm being honest there were
so many people who
lurkers even whose names i didn't
recognize from being chatters but who
had been long-time community members
came out of the woodwork to kind of say
this is the first time i've been able to
play this game like i've been watching
you stream this game for a year now
and oh my god i finally get to play and
that was beautiful
a just seeing the like pure joy from
people's reactions but it was also
really eye-opening in the sense that
there were so many people that i like i
was aware at large there are members of
the dead by daylight community that want
to play the game and can't but it's so
different hearing from people directly
hearing people say i've sat on the
sidelines and watched you enjoy this for
a year and you know i haven't been able
to participate and now i finally can
yeah that's amazing i felt very
surprised i don't think i got any trolls
with any kind of negativity it was
largely like us just celebrating and
also just cheering each other on like
every time somebody would say oh my god
i finally get to play dead by daylight
at least five or six people were adding
them in the chat saying i'm so happy for
you welcome let us know if you want
someone to practice with
which was really nice i actually think
it's pretty rare um these days i'm not
sure why i just thought of this but
the the fact that
they not only have like added all these
different accessibility um
options and things
but with how long the game's been out
too yeah like it's it's been like yeah
yeah it really was
last year from from my perspective that
they um probably not even my perspective
factually it was last year that they
really got it together and
and it's been since what 2016. yeah it's
been a while which is awesome like and i
feel like that's such a good good reason
to talk about the game is like
just because you didn't have it on
launch doesn't mean that you can't now
you know like for any devs you happen to
be watching this just because you didn't
do it initially doesn't mean you can't
iterate on that and and give your game
more longevity and and open it up to
even a new audience right now um but
it's not a small audience either it's a
lot of people so i think it's something
that is is totally worth doing even if
it's ten years later it's still going to
be important to players
yeah that's a great point
[Music]
are we back hey
i'm just trying to see if there's
pizza
it's
it's a pro alana for goodness sake
oh my god oh
but i just uh what you know broke this i
can smell it and i'm just trying to
pizza pay for that you're gonna have to
pay them back pizza you know what i'm
saying oh this one's heavy steve it's
heavy
uh-huh it's heavy and there's a raccoon
in there in there oh my god
oh you found the joker we found the
pizza look at you i'm taking it
i'm my own boss nobody can tell me that
i can't eat
nobody's allowed
i just told you no you don't count
no
no
i'm not having it okay
also i'm still pretty sure that you did
that dead by daylight video just so that
you could repeatedly mounted me
i did not murder you for the record
you actually didn't it was very polite
of you but i hadn't played that game in
a really long time and i had forgotten
all of the controls so i was mostly just
very scared of steve while having
trying to have a really serious
conversation it went great it went great
yeah you know the thing about
accessibility and by daylight we we
could have featured a bunch of different
games here but one of the main reasons
why we decided on dead by daylight was
simply
you don't have to include everything at
watch now not all studios are really
really good at listening to their
communities they're not necessarily
great at hearing the feedback from the
community um you know alana's got to get
involved in some i've had to get
involved in some sometimes you need a
champion to get their attention and it
you know we're trying to make that less
so we're trying to make it so that
anybody can reach out and say hey this
needs to be more accessible that's part
of what we're trying to do here yeah you
do have to advocate for yourself as well
and if you can't
let us know we'll have a kit for you
that's what we're here to do but they
did do a really really good job of
you know progressively updating on a lot
of accessibility features with dead by
daylight specifically and i think like
the coolest part of that video is
hearing [ __ ] origins talk about how
certain members of her community were
slowly able to join the game as they
added more options and how emotional
that was and that's like such a
testament to why this is so important
it's a huge testament and it's also a
great opportunity to bring up that there
are still people in the dead by daylight
community who feel that the
accessibility has not reached them yet
and it's an art in progress it's
something that continues to need
addressed and it should be in every game
where you don't just stop at one
particular percentage of the disability
community continually reach out to more
and more as you can
strongly agree and that's what we're
here for
well you're eating pizza
i can agree while eating pizza you can't
stop me for the record i was not told to
do this i just really wanted to eat the
pizza
she's literally eating the pizza while
i'm sitting here being a really good
host and not putting pizza in my mouth
mm-hmm
sucks to be you
story of my life
our next presenter got his big break
co-starring with me in an internet
commercial to help raise 1 million
for charity in 2020. we thought we'd do
him a huge favor and bring him back
again for a little more exposure
nice
[Music]
let me go from that to wholesome here's
an inspiring entrepreneur family man
canadian actor and champion of all
things john candy your friendly
neighborhood deadpool ryan reynolds
well hi there i'm ryan reynolds uh and
i'm presenting the award for second
channel uh this category is for games
that allow you to get information from
multiple sources at the same time uh
it's sort of like when you play fortnite
you can identify where another player
might be shooting you from uh from
hearing them shoot with directional
audio
uh by seeing their muzzle flash or those
little um
little directional indicator thingy that
pops up to let you know that you're
taking damage
not that that's ever happened to me
uh second channel is important for
gamers with cognitive disabilities uh
blind gamers deaf gamers gamers with low
vision or low hearing because adding
additional ways to tell you the same
information ensures that you're on a
level playing field with everyone else
so that being said without further ado
here are the nominees
and the nominees are
before your eyes goodbye world games
skybound games
we have to make him do this every
birthday
unpacking witch beam humble bundle
guardians of the galaxy idos montreal
square enix
and the winner is
guardians of the galaxy congratulations
[Music]
hi i'm amelian accessibility lead for
squarenex west based out of eidos
montreal and i'm jean francois diga the
senior creative director on marvel's
guardians of the galaxy at the end of
montreal
today i want to give a big thank you to
the video game accessibility awards and
ablegamers for this humbling recognition
we also wanted to thank our dev team
champions accessibility advocates who
even made this award possible thank you
to marvel as well for encouraging us in
this mission
also a huge congrats to the other
nominees your work is very inspiring in
this mission and obviously gaming is for
everyone so congratulations to you as
well and finally a big thank you to you
all the fans around the world your love
and passion for this game is truly
rewarding thank you so much thank you
[Music]
one thing that's very cool about this is
the spotlight on all of the
accessibility leads i feel like there's
people that you don't really see
do interviews very often and there are
accessibility teams a lot of aaa studios
it's really nice that they're actually
like letting them be the ones to accept
a lot of the awards it's cool yeah i
appreciate this not just them putting
out the same spokesperson again and
again it's actually the people who care
about accessibility and who are on the
forefront frightening with the rest of
us yeah we appreciate you um steve i do
also have to ask
you did end up paying ryan reynolds his
28 million dollar speaking fee right uh
you know you don't have to that's not a
stats 28 millionaire that's not uh not
important right now actually uh can we
afford to do the rest of the show
i'm going to just avoid all right well
um next up is one of my best friends and
all around softboy crank gameplays ethan
is a super versatile award-winning
content creator and one of our returning
presenters also before we get into this
one we did have a different approach the
acceptance speech for this one you'll
see here's ethan
hi my name is ethan nester or crank
gameplays and i am here to present the
award for house rules house rules is a
category devoted to games that allow the
players to make their own rules this
past year one game really stood out in
particular it was an absolute worldwide
phenomenon and it always kept
accessibility in mind to keep the
players playing together and playing the
way that they wanted and so
our board unanimously decided on one
single nominee
and that nominee and winner was a little
game called among us among us had tons
of features inside of it like built-in
preset communication settings you could
customize your controller or keyboard
and mouse settings there were different
roles and modes that you could apply to
the game so you could play it with your
friends the way that you wanted to but
don't just take my word for it let's
hear a little bit more about among us
from v train
sorry lavar they uh
they made me say that
so thank you for yeah
coming to chat to us today um we have a
category that was in last year's
accessibility awards which is called
house rules which is specifically
um
about allowing players to make their own
rules so we kind of wanted to ask you a
couple of questions because uh you guys
won last year um and yeah we didn't
actually include the the category in
this year's show um
steve what was the reason for that
you're downplaying it just just just a
little bit like you could you could you
could hype it up just a little bit he's
technically correct yeah so the reason
that we didn't include it in this year's
show is because uh the votes were 100
unanimous for among us
meaning that you 100 won so graduation
for the second year in a row wow
we chose not even to announce the
nominees ahead of time because all votes
went to among us so the point of us
bringing you here today is say to say
congratulations you have once again won
the house rules category um
with unanimous votes meaning you did an
incredible
okay so i kind of wanted to say like you
know is is there of course you are the
community manager like you said you
didn't necessarily design these features
but i thought it would be a cool
opportunity to ask like have you seen
people do
some cool stuff what's your favorite
parts about uh house rules like do you
have any insight to how it's been
received by among us players since the
game like really blew up in 2020
yeah i mean so the thing is like we
launched uh new roles to the game
recently and those are also customizable
in terms of like how many you can have
and like the percentage chance of them
appearing um and all that and it is one
of the really cool things to just see
the ways
different kinds of ways that people take
our game and
um play it and
yeah create their own house rules i'm
not sure if there's like a particular
favorite that i have honestly
just because now it's so varied
especially with the different roles that
it's hard to pinpoint
um
but it is it is something that it is
still like we see it in our discord we i
see it on social where people are
talking about how
um they change it up depending on like
if they're playing it with their
classroom if they're playing it for a
birthday party if they're playing with
their family uh
yeah it's it is really cool to see and
it's really cool that we have 100 pounds
of boats
i rigged it that's ridiculous yeah
the reason i think you keep winning and
why you got 100 this year is because
there's very few games that allow you to
match make with a group of like-minded
individuals let alone people that have
the same abilities or to be able to make
sure that those abilities are accounted
for and the options and when it comes to
among us you're able to enable things or
some things like the symbols that are
put on liars that you know everyone kind
of just glossed over like it was no big
deal but it's a huge accessibility
feature that's just baked right into the
game do you sort of have some thoughts
on you know how that's been as the
community manager like getting to see
the disability community be able to play
with various disabilities victoria i
feel like this is the point where i
should tell you that i am recording this
and it will be in the show who really
sprung that on you however like we'll
let you watch this back before we leave
okay
oh i did not know this we'll let you
watch this back before we include it we
couldn't tell you ahead of time or it
would have ruined us telling you that
you won the award yeah we tried to
figure out how to do that i will i will
send you an edit of this first though so
that you can actually watch it now i
feel like i should have been like way
more put together
it's more exciting this way
also i look you know it's fine
i told her she looked like a college kid
doing this he did say that right before
he joined yeah so no the the general
question though was just simply you know
the reason that among us continues to
win is because it does include so many
different options for so many different
people with disabilities that have
varying ranges of abilities you know
obviously it's something that means a
lot to that community how does it feel
to sort of sit in your chair as
community manager and really view that
from the top down
honestly
genuinely amazing and i say this with
like
an asterix because like as cool as it is
that we won 100 like 100 of the votes
and all of that um i do still want to
caveat that it's still there's still
work to be done and i don't think we're
perfect and the team is like aware of
this too right like we do want to add
like more um colorblind accessibility
features and other things like that um
but seeing like the reception to it and
seeing people being able to play and
especially from my position in community
the fact uh that i get to like read a
lot of the stories of people coming
together and saying that oh like there's
finally a game that they can play with
their family and their friends and like
the tasks are simple enough that you
know a lot of even people who aren't
gamers or whatever
they label themselves as um can play and
enjoy it is really cool to me uh so yeah
it means a lot to me it means a lot to
the team so that's awesome yeah i mean
you're doing an amazing job and we just
felt like this one was extra special
because of course it was our only award
that had 100 unanimous votes and i can
strongly agree with it and definitely
appreciate this conversation steve and
i've been having a lot um the push to
continue because it does require the
community to tell you what they need and
then you listen to that feedback and
take it to the team and i think
accessibility is something that should
be ongoing that currently a lot of
studios are treating is like whatever we
have on launch is it and i think that
that we should be treating it as
something that can evolve the same way
we treat a million other things or bug
fixes even like they can evolve why can
we not treat accessibility the same way
so
team is doing a fantastic job
congratulations on winning sorry for
springing this on you in this way she's
not sorry
i'd love to watch you suffer
um you know that's okay we've we've made
a lot of people suffer playing among us
so
every time i get a poster i cry so
thanks for that
[Music]
i still feel bad about that
i feel like you're adult though like i i
i can't get i i feel like nothing has
changed about you at all
yeah steve you aware that there's like
progressively more and more
pizza boxes behind you
who's doing that uh i don't think there
are it's been it's a stagnant set we're
just sitting here in a living room and
shooting video i i feel like
like
because if you're going to talk about
changes like are you aware that your
sequin dress is now a pizza sequin dress
yeah you were wearing a dress earlier it
was blue so it matched my like
definitely been wearing this the whole
time i
don't think i was i live by the pizza i
die by the pizza steve okay
that's my motto i always say that you're
a meme can't wait for that one i text
you that all the time
come on you say so meme lord whatever uh
you know i think the the great thing to
talk about with uh little house rules
there is
how it's just one of many many
patterns that are available on
accessible games the place where we got
our inspiration for all of these
categories you can go check it out right
now it's a free resource available by
ablegamers and that's where we we got a
lot of this from but it's specifically
because we wanted to honor a category
where people could choose to play
together as even of a playing ground as
possible so even if i'm really good at
killer and alan is very good at dying uh
we can play together
who's
by what logic
you're so rude
what listen i'm being bullied
only one of us is currently draped in
pepperoni it's not me so i don't know
what you're talking about let's buy the
pizza dive by the pizza
thank you pizza hut we appreciate you
you did a great job
oh
man we'll never live this now okay
anyway
our next presenter goes by no hands and
zed i said that right i'm so proud of
myself and runs no hands no excuses
because
he has no hands why you felt like you
needed to put that on the prompter he is
a content creator and motivational
twitch partner and really likes making
fun of alana for being australian it's
true god damn kiwis
kia ora folks it is an absolute honor to
be back for the video game accessibility
awards once again i am humphrey hanley
aka no hands nz and i play video games
with no hands all while advocating for
greater accessibility and inclusion for
everyone
which is why it gives me great pleasure
to present the award for one of my most
used accessibility features
remapping
remapping is a category for games that
allow players to change their button
layouts on the controller or adjust
their keyboard and mouse controls for a
customized input
that caters to how they like to play
remapping is critical for players with
physical and cognitive disabilities
because it allows buttons to be mapped
to
a position that is easier to reach or
makes the game possible to play in the
first place
without further ado here are your
nominees
and the nominees are
ratchet and clank ripped apart insomniac
games sony interactive entertainment
it takes two hazelite studios electronic
arts
[Music]
um right oh god oh god oh god oh god
final fantasy 14 end walker square enix
and the winner of the remapping category
is
final fantasy 14 end walker
congratulations
[Music]
we are honored to have final fantasy 14
end walker win the 2021 video game
accessibility award for remapping
it is important to us to make games
accessible to as many players as
possible and we are glad to have been
able to evolve the game throughout the
years based on the helpful feedback from
our community
we look forward to finding new ways to
bring further accessibility to final
fantasy 14 online in the future
thank you all so much
[Music]
that game rolls
you
you you're wait where did the pizza go i
don't it's right here what's happening
literally right here that's
i don't understand what's going on here
i don't know
are you okay
i'm not sure i think i may be delirious
from pizzaism i don't know no it's only
good for you
we only say positive things about pizza
that's right only positive pizza go
pizza
i love that they won this category for
remapping especially as they've
continued to try to get a little bit
better with accessibility over the years
they still got a ways to go i still you
know harp on them about things like
mouse sensitivity but again a running
theme of this show keep making things
better as as you can uh but you know i'm
guessing a lot you don't remember
because you're 18 i think you said so
you you've got a couple of years old
here but uh you know back in the day
remapping was something that
was considered outlandish it was it was
considered
to be annoying when disabled people
would reach out and say hey remapping's
really important now it's standard and
now it's something that we all look
forward to in video games no matter our
abilities it is um very important for me
personally i was only able to play sifu
because they have remapping i have
tendonitis in both my wrist that is my
particular accessibility issue where any
rapid button tapping is extremely
painful for me and i will just get slow
and bad and have to ice my wrists and
eventually they will kind of lock up
i've had to wear wrist braces for months
it makes it difficult to play video
games which sucks i can't play most
fighting games these days i have a lot
of trouble with guitar hero or anything
that i can't remap anything that i can't
remap that that middle button from uh
rapid tapping that's why like holds are
really important instead of mashes as
well so
it's definitely something that's very
important to me and i definitely
appreciate all of the nominees and a lot
of other games that one featured in the
nominees list obviously who've done a
really good job um i believe that it
takes two did a really good job with
remapping as well so very important like
steve stead thank you sorry next year
fight for our love companies get your
game accessible maybe you'll be able to
be sponsored by a pizza you could be on
this show it could be a good dream
i don't understand how did you get back
in the dress though i don't understand
that's not i don't
i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about um but seriously we're
like well over halfway through the
categories at this point
where is zach can we check in on him
again is he getting closer at least
[Music]
oh the cute little spaceman i finally
feel safe here i just feel like nothing
bad can happen here did any of you
little spacemen order a spicy hawaiian
chicken pizza
oh [ __ ] they've got lasers too oh god
oh no
even these cute little spacemen are
murderers how could a murderer be so
adorable emergency meeting
it's pizza time
and also there's a dead body
okay well maybe i'll just slide this
pizza into a vent then
[Music]
he's uh he's never gonna make it is he
no he's in space for the second time i
guess a little little sus if you ask me
yeah he went on a halo and then went to
a dungeon and now he's in a space
station um again supposed to be
delivering pizzas to nominees and award
winners
yo i feel like somehow that got lost in
the script and so did he
maybe that's my fault i don't know we'll
figure it out i'm really sorry everybody
i know that you wanted to see zach very
specifically you're all asking for it
all over social media for him to deliver
pizza to the studios
delivery it was everywhere trended it
was viral
i'm very sorry we let you down thanks
again rock for getting that going uh
you know
the only thing i'm thankful for here is
we haven't had to endure alana's robotic
voice this year and that makes me happy
as we come towards the end of the show
um thank you steve the nominees are
gosh i could do it i promise you
promised me you weren't gonna do it i
did all the nominee speeches for last
year by myself but in different accents
because it made steve uncomfortable um
i'm gonna bring it back next
understatement can we make that trend
too next to where is zack anna
make it happen no
our next presenter is a youtube streamer
who's very well known for hitting
impossible sniper shots being a family
man and doing huge charity streams every
year he's a content creator who shows
that it's possible to get the bag while
also looking out for others here is dr
lupo
hey everybody dribble here and i am
presenting the award for input reduction
uh this award is for games that allow
players to reduce the amount of times
they have to press certain buttons or
click their mice or hit certain keys on
their keyboards basically it gives you
the ability to do more than one thing
with one button at a time thus reducing
the input needed to successfully
complete tasks and games uh this
shouldn't be confused with remapping
which lets you swap where buttons are
input reduction is all about making sure
you can press buttons less often
input reduction is especially important
for players with any upper limb
disabilities anything caught any
cognitive disability or any disability
where automating tasks can enable us to
play more comfortably or for longer very
important now here are the nominees
and the nominees are
before your eyes goodbye world games
skybound game
fights in tight spaces ground shatter
mode 7 games
escape from tarkov battle state games
and the winner is
before your eyes congratulations
[Music]
hello uh on behalf of the team i want to
say that this award and this event means
so much to us
fixing accessibility problems is a
question of creativity and we really
believe that more imagination and more
experimentation means wider
accessibility for games and for society
developers i really encourage you to try
new things and to talk to and consult
with people with disabilities as a part
of your process if we keep doing these
things then the future of gaming is
going to be a good one
[Music]
i actually met some of the members of
the team uh from goodbye world and uh at
dyson they were so so so passionate
about accessibility it was really cool
to talk to them about it and to see them
win is also awesome
fixing accessibility is a matter of
creativity i feel like that needs to be
put on a
bumper sticker or a plaque or like that
was that was actually great as long as i
said earlier we did not view these
videos ahead of time to get honest
reactions and that is amazing i i love
that quote and i think it's something we
should we should live by here yeah i
strongly agree it's also uh input
reduction is another one that's really
important to me it makes my life a lot
easier if i can reduce the amount of
inputs like i said any button mashing is
a problem so
they did it in a very creative way um if
you haven't played that game it's it's
very very very unique basically you can
advance things by blinking
uh it's it's very cool and steve we
spoke about this earlier it's basically
like
taking something that is an
accessibility option but making it this
creative fun mechanic at the same time
accessibility doesn't have to be boring
not at all
it can be fun it can be full of pizza it
can be a giant award show
we got you
next up is one of the sweetest streamers
i've ever collaborated with and this
year's featured vtuber tiffany witcher
is an award-winning streamer
accessibility advocate and consultant
and voice actor here's tiffany
good time zone my friends i'm tiffany
witcher and i'm known as the charity
witch on twitch i'm a charity streamer
accessibility advocate consultant and
voice actor i am presenting the award
for improved precision this category is
for recognizing the games that allow you
to customize mouse and controller
sensitivity improved position is
especially important for players with
disabilities who may need slower faster
or more precise movement to move the
camera in game
here are the nominees
and the nominees are
chivalry two torn banner studios
tripwire interactive
cry 6 ubisoft toronto ubisoft
[Music]
back for blood turtle rock studios
warner brothers interactive
entertainment
and the winner is far cry 6.
[Music]
hi i'm david kaveri narrative director
on far cry 6. i'm honored to accept this
award on behalf of the teams at ubisoft
toronto and ubisoft kiev who played a
central role in making far cry 6 the
most accessible game in the far cry
franchise
our hearts go out to our ukrainian
colleagues their families and loved ones
during this unthinkable war
we stand with our teams in ukraine
thank you for creating these awards to
recognize the work of developers across
our industry to make games more
accessible to more players
[Music]
i respect the hell out of that
same i did not know he was going to do
that and that is awesome
obviously shout out to ukraine
i love the awesome reactions we get here
uh managing to straddle both the worlds
that matter to us most yeah
also like to shout out to the production
team for managing the show the one clip
where i got slaughtered in chivalry
[Laughter]
yeah i saw the one clip yeah the one
clip yeah that's not what i'm talking to
me no never i've never lost in a video
game legitimately ever never one time
everyone else is always cheating
every time it's really weird especially
when i'm playing solitaire it's so
strange
[Laughter]
so our next presenter is known as chris
he is the one who has been providing the
asl on deaf gamers tv hopefully you've
tuned in there as well he is a
accessibility reviewer consultant plus
an amazing content creator chris has
been live this entire time through his
switch channel and you better have been
following him there so if you haven't
done so yet go do it now
i did also want to mention that uh the
vo for this particular segment we had
done by somebody that you might know um
it is roger clark
who voices arthur morgan in red dead
redemption 2. so here is chris hello
available
hello my name is chris
you may know me as deaf gamers tv
what am i doing
i'm presenting the award for clear text
what's that
that's when a game let us change text
size
for captions
subtitles
and ui like menus
also for games that let you change
colors for subtitles
background
and sometimes let you add effect like
blurs or shadows so you can even see it
with white snowy background in-game
that's what clear text is
clear text is particularly important for
deaf players players with low vision
color deficiencies and or learning
disabilities like dyslexia
here we go here are the nominees
and the nominees are
boyfriend dungeon kid fox games
loop hero four quarters devolver digital
halo infinite 343 industries xbox game
studios
to win
[Music]
to be a sport
and the winner is
it's halo infinity
yay
[Music]
hi my name is paige and i'm a technical
ux designer here at 343 industries i'm
incredibly honored to be here today to
accept this award on behalf of my team a
huge thanks to my team and all of my
colleagues that worked so hard on making
our text clear and accessible a huge
thanks to alana steve ablegamers and
everyone that's here today to celebrate
accessibility and gaming we're
incredibly grateful for the feedback and
partnership that we've had with the
gaming and disability community to make
our user interface and our game more
accessible we're excited to continue on
our journey to improve thank you
[Music]
a huge congrats to halo infinite for
winning two awards this year
what killed like a collaboration too
between our presenters there that was
that was neat actually yeah i was so
stoked to get to do that to ask roger
clark to provide vo for chris who is
obviously doing awesome work for us
please go follow chris everybody he's
he's awesome um was very very cool like
i said arthur morgan red dead redemption
2 was so so neat to i don't know have so
many people be a part of this whole show
and we are actually at the end those are
all of our winners this year so thank
you everybody at home for watching we
appreciate you an enormous thank you to
our partners at pizza hut for making
this so much bigger if you saw last
year's show i was literally in my
kitchen with a
green screen behind me
and now
i'm in a real room you know it's not a
green screen because i got the pizza off
the wall there's pizza here
i'm really going to talk about getting
more pizza next year
no that's great i'm really glad we were
able to do this again again hang on
there's somebody at the door just give
me a second
hello
zach
pizza's here pizza time you're not
supposed to be here
you're supposed to be delivering pizzas
to to the studios to the nominees
oh
what are you doing here i'm here with
pizza for you did you go to outer space
and then come back to l.a i did
this has been a very like not uh
efficient route for well i feel like you
should just get just carry that and then
just i've eaten some of it to be honest
damn it zach
maybe it's next year i just do my best
i just do it for accessibility all right
i'll see you then
when do i get paid
i can't
so who was that i don't
you know so that was zack anna
um showed up just here in person uh he
did bring me more pizza so
this actually has a pizza in it i
thought that he he was going to eat the
whole thing
he made it to set just not the right set
i mean he technically did deliver a
pizza which is what we paid him to do so
technically he's got you okay you're
right maybe we should pay him after all
yeah oh wait we didn't oh crap we'll get
to that but really thank you all so much
for watching uh steve i did cut you off
to answer the door
yeah well you're kind of rude so that's
i'm just i apologize
yeah uh no you know uh we appreciate
everybody out there who uh helped with
accessibility everybody was part of the
show thank you to our sponsors and thank
you so much for everybody who made this
happen this year it was amazing and i'm
glad we're able to do it again my
special thanks to alana pierce uh
despite all of our bravado on the
internet and joking with each other she
is an amazing human who cares a lot
about accessibility so make sure that
you give her the props and the follows
and oh pizza coupons yeah i'm okay i've
got all the pizza i need but yeah thank
you we of course like this is our second
year there are things that we would want
to change and do differently that we
will keep iterating on in terms of
categories and nominees and how we
approach all of that stuff for a bigger
and better show so thank you for
watching thank you to everybody at real
good touring for helping us put this all
together and to pizza hut and to you
steve and the audience we'll see you
next year
bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you